what's taking the ps4 end-of-the-year
closed out that you're pretty strong
with exclusives again to games that we
didn't know when we would finally see
nope
until we saw him and then we reviewed
him before Peter Brown both of them nope
what one final fantasy is not exclusive
sorry yeah I like what you're saying
nope over and over what am I saying
wrong
yeah reveling in as you kept talking
secretly it's been a long episode yes
but yes ps4 to new iterations of the ps4
have released this year again we saw a
few exclusives we kind of you know saw
the beginning of this like this these
consoles being updated much like you
might PC almost maybe not as often or is
in depth but ps4 slim released peels
talk about that quick what did that
change it was just the size was it like
what like of the hardware would make us
appealing to someone who didn't
initially have a ps4 cheaper smaller I
think just more pleasing in terms of
both as aesthetic and the materials that
it uses and it came with HDR support
which now is supported by the entire
PlayStation Line
but yeah it's just like a more refined
system I think there is like the
original design was sort of like wow
look at this like very like you know
slick design thing and now it's just
like alright it's just a good game
console we've handed a little bit
smoother so that's it I like the
original design more yeah yeah like the
sharp edges you're allogram kind of
thing yeah all right I forget if it's a
parallelogram or a rhombus one of those
is the other I'm not a geometry ps4 pro
a few months later hit me with that why
would I want to get this more power
that's it
HDR HDR is is you know that's you can
get that on any of the Playstations 4k
is a thing but it's you know it's not
perfect there's a lot of issue it's some
don't some do some yeah it's like this
sort of fears I had when Microsoft was
talking with the Scorpio d3 was like
true 4k gaming it's like stop lying to
people like yeah so you're not gonna get
60 frames per second 4k at the same
fidelity you had at 1080p and you know
yes the Scorpio may be more powerful
than the pro but here we are with a
system that has upgraded that is
offering a very similar promise
and it's kind of doing it but Natalie
comes with a bigger hard drive on the
pro that's nice
doesn't it race blu-ray blu-ray doesn't
have UHD whd support yeah
which Scorpio does does we don't know
that's does subscribe you'll know next
up yeah they need to come up with a new
name because Scorpio nests are similar
what were you gonna say J uh I mean I
think with the ps4 Pro at least it seems
more it seems like something if you
don't have a ps4 it would be good to get
I guess and if you have a 4k HDR TV or
if you don't like I don't know it's cool
that you have that option but I don't
think I'd get it at least not right now
no and it's like a lot of people were
hoping and I'm glad it didn't turn out
this way because I it I don't sound like
a liar after the fact but it does not
benefit PlayStation VR you still have to
use that breakout box everyone say oh
you're gonna have to do it with the pro
it's gonna be this VR machine it that's
not the case yeah PSP are you just
brought it up I know it's a segue thank
you I'm getting tired you're not okay
I'm very tired
alright so psvr like we talked about
this extensively earlier on the show
there's the first year we have an actual
VR category in our end of the year
rewards psvr is most accessible by price
and i think again if you're not if you
weren't really on the lookout for VR and
you see that it's there for your console
that you've owned for years go for it I
guess like just go for it
just get it get after it in terms of the
software library we mentioned this a
little bit hit or miss kind of junior
said he thinks a few titles are like
worth purchasing above their weight yeah
I mean I don't really worry about them
being exclusive or not right I think
yeah just the fact that it's great on a
console alone is special would be
thumper it's an amazing VR game and that
works wonders on ps4 res is a ps4
exclusive resident finit and that is
special as well a few misses you know
along the way like Russia blood what was
the series until dawn right but I was
like on Rails we were gonna stand alone
going through an amusement park
firing like guns I mean it the software
needs to catch up and we don't really
have a great sense of what the next
great VR title will be for PlayStation 4
but it's certainly like it's easy to set
up it works well and it's comfortable to
use as a matter of time for developers
to say okay cool people like this let
even what they want as a fan of Resident
Evil I'm hoping resonable makes good use
but I played it I'm not totally
convinced yet but you know maybe when
I'm playing through an entire
playthrough I'll change my mind
it also was a sorry what I was gonna say
I hope that even if I don't love VR and
Resident Evil 7 for the whole time you
know it uses those tapes to like put
your new scenarios I can imagine just
like distinct like one-off moments in
that game where you're like I want this
moment in VR yeah to feel like you have
to do the whole well yeah we mention
this early you could just you go one
playthrough you could load up a safe
right VR whenever you don't have to
dedicate your commit to one VR
playthrough one just standard
playthrough so that would be like ease
of use in general and you know Jimmy was
saying this is probably the most
comfortable headset it is yeah by far is
you've solved pretty extensively yeah no
it's it's so simple to use and it's
balanced really well it's heavier than I
think the vibe but you wouldn't know it
so I think psvr accomplished what it
needed to as far as like bringing VR to
that audience and I think you know like
it's showing promise definitely and like
I said here's hoping it you know follows
through with resin evil 7 it's akin to
the games before we close out the show
the Last Guardian most recent we talked
we didn't ask the reviewer with you
earlier in the show you know if you want
to watch that you can go dive into that
on your own but I do want to touch on it
yeah great game we gave out 9 out of 10
despite some frustrations this nailed it
after what 10 years in development yeah
it is it is just an amazing game that
you you can't point to anything parallel
on any other platform I mean it's it's
not that it could only be done on
PlayStation 4 but that's the only place
you can play it yeah you really I think
everyone should experience Las Guardian
I'm gonna bounce back and forth between
like bigger games and some like not like
it's such huge Triple A games Jake you
brought up alienation today from a house
mark house Marky House Marky Mark how
smart I was right the first time
stop me when I'm in this I was like Jake
you and I have played this cooperatively
a lot I kind of like had the same kind
of it's like Diablo makes with
Helldivers we played those two I don't
know what you liked this game alott yeah
I had a lot of fun with it
we didn't play as much as I would have
liked but you and I together played
quite a bit and I think it's just it it
does have a lot of those kind of
complexities that Diablo does like the
loot grinding but it still has that
great sort of feel to it that how smart
games typically have at least you know
most people think of resogun in it it
plays great it feels great it's a lot of
fun especially if you've got co-op
I know at first it launched though and I
don't think there was couch co-op but
now there is it's definitely worth
looking into
I think this isn't a console exclusive
anymore the witness originally released
for ps4 and Windows I believe in January
and then September it's since come to
Xbox one but originally it was a ps4
exclusive I review this gave it a 9 out
of 10 this is one of my favorite games
of the year
I think this games really important it's
tough to show it in game play like we're
showing now I'm sure you've heard of it
by now it's a thing it was really famous
just cuz Jonathan Blow who did parade
worked on you know like you can call
braid and this game pretentious and I
think they very much are to a certain
extent but this game is really special I
think they take these mazes and they
take the world and tie them together and
tell this really cool contextual
environmental story in such a way that
it is one of my most memorable
experiences one of the hardest games
I've ever played one of the most like
intellectually challenging and just
tested my patience in so many ways
throughout the process but it's well
worth checking out and I think the ps4
was a better off the beginning this year
for it you're like a psychopath in your
view yeah like a notebook that you'd
open up like write things down you like
yeah Michael hi Omar associate tech
editor was uh I he had a notebook open
his desk today are you playing the
witness he's like yeah finally getting
into Z that I think everybody has that
like psychopath like serial killer
notebook someone head of human skin yes
made of hair in oh it's weird is that
after a while you're just writing down
people you're gonna kill you just start
looking more and more like Jonathan
below the more you play it so you have a
beginning this year a ps4 kicks it off
really well with that uh big game
followed in March maybe may I reviewed
this game I should know when I released
uncharted for probably the bigger
exclusive cipher made The Last Guardian
for ps4 this year Naughty Dog it was the
first Uncharted without Amy Hennig
writing of you know like she doesn't
look she's doing like working on Star
Wars titles now EA and everything and I
really love this game I gave it a ten
out of ten you could throw food at me if
you want or something tomatoes if we
were in a crowded theater hall no
I love this game I think they not only
did it tell an amazing character driven
nuanced story on its own in a world that
with moments I have not forgotten yet
and I don't think I ever will
it actually addressed Nathan Drake as a
character from the first three games it
made the first three games even more
powerful I don't love the first game I
think the two is fantastic game like I
think the general consensus is 3 I think
stumbled a little bit but I still love
it for I think it's the best entire game
it is one of my favorite games ever I
love this game I love the beset pieces
in it like just being dragged to the mud
on these trucks jumping from truck to
truck and motorcycle a motorcycle in
Madagascar this these it's gorgeous
I can't say enough about it I want to
talk about it more before so we don't
have time but Jake I know you liked and
tried Pete you both like on tried for a
lot yeah I think like at least my
favorite thing with uncharted 4 is that
like uncharred 1 2 & 3 those series felt
very much about Nathan Drake and this
one does too
but it does put a lot of focus on a lot
of its sidekick there's something that
you're actually bringing up yesterday
like Elena
plays a huge role in this like just
those two interacting and there's like a
great scene that I know we've talked
about a lot yeah yeah or there's one one
in particular that I think you don't
talk about
and then slowly to and it's just it's
just a beautiful ending to a series that
I've grown so attached to I don't think
it's just like a great like Indiana
Jones esque story anymore I think they
actually explored how his actions and
his adventures have affected the people
around him and I think it was pretty
powerful and I think if you finished the
game you know it kind of becomes about
why these stories can be important and
like the PIO they can help people I
thought it was an amazing game in every
single way and then no man's sky really
sudden you know ps4 back in June yes
we've been waiting for that for a while
and again another game with a long
development cycle Pete naturally you
would review it as you did the rest of
this year you like this game you give a
7 out of 10 for my remember and since
been updated with a big past adds these
freighters in base building which Rob
said makes me better but doesn't like
drastically change it but uh yeah I
think a lot of people there's a lot of
[ __ ] surrounding this game now because
you know whether it be like developer
promises like percieve developer
promises whether they deliver on that
I don't know but in general you you seem
to like this game I mean they basically
promised a slicker more accessible EVE
Online and and what we got was not that
yeah you can't meet other people in the
world even if you are on the same planet
you will not see them you will run into
stuff that people named but that's about
it and so what what you're left with is
just a massive galaxy where you're
hopping between star systems and it all
happens very seamlessly with kind of
trippy spectacle that just adds a bit of
magic to the whole process and then you
dive down into these planets and explore
you know some are very pleasant some are
very hazardous some have no resources at
all and you've doomed yourself by
landing and walking away from your ship
others are just rich and bountiful and
you're leaving behind like it's that old
story of like you know someone trying to
carry a too much treasure out of a you
know a place in like dooming themselves
because they were so greedy I mean this
game you can kill yourself by being too
greedy because you're spending too much
time and just dying very fascinating
game for a lot of reasons but it's
missing that the heart and soul like the
only motivation in the game other two is
one to get to the center of the galaxy
and two is to follow this path this
thing called Atlas is sort of beckoning
you I found that to be really fulfilling
it was kind of short-lived and it was
very linear and how it was told so while
very interesting it wasn't enough to
elevate the game to like a a must played
game mm-hmm really happy I played it I
think I put like 70 hours into it and I
could I could have played a little bit
more definitely if not for new games
yeah and obviously again it's been
updated since very recently about a week
ago and you can play it in that updated
form now so yeah overall pretty strong
lineup for ps4 this year there was no
blood-borne so that's a bummer
there's no blood-borne two yet and let's
hope that get announced blow storms part
of my game of the year there's no end of
last year but still anyway so yeah again
if you're watching this live it's not up
yet but if you're watching this on
youtube or GameSpot you can read the
more in-depth end-of-the-year report
card for ps4 written by one of our
editors and go check that
you